das wollen wir mal eine kleine bilanz
ziehen jetzt zwar die ifa dieses jahr
auf jeden fall ordentlich anders als
sonst hat es sich ihrer meinung nach
gelohnt
in der tat war die ifa an das ist es
nicht die große internationale globale
eva mit vielen händlern mit vielen
fachbesuchern und mit viel publikum vor
allem natürlich auch mit vielen
konsumenten sondern wir mussten deswegen
corona deutlich verkleinern
es hat sich wahnsinnig gelohnt hat sich
in doppelter hinsicht gelohnt wir haben
nicht nur hier viele medien zusammen
gebracht wir haben nicht nur die
aussteller zusammen gebracht mit
fachbesuchern die sich alle gefreut
haben weil wir zusammen zu kommen
sondern wir haben auch damit in der
medienwelt online und den traditionellen
medien tv viel mehr kontakte weltweit
gehabt als letztes jahr zur gleichen
zeit das zeigt man hat auf die ifa
gewartet wir haben gute nachrichten und
alle freuen sich dass wir überhaupt
stattfinden
man hat ja auch gesehen dass die
industrie jetzt glücklich war überhaupt
mal wieder was präsentieren zu können
ist weihnachten gerettet für uns
consumer elektronik fans ist eine der
ganz spannenden fragen weil consumer
electronics home appliances
elektrohausgeräte tv-geräte ausrüstung
für das home office ist natürlich jetzt
den letzten wochen bereits massiv und
viel gekauft wurden und jetzt fragt sich
die industrie einerseits ist alles schon
vorgezogen wurden passiert weihnachten
noch etwas aber wir sind wir sind da
wesentlich optimistischer für zwei
gründe zum einen mann kann ich so viel
reisen also das budget der konsumenten
ist dieses jahr etwas anders aufgeteilt
aber zum zweiten es gibt viele neuen
gerät neue geräte der innovationszyklus
in der industrie ist kürzer als sechs
monate an vielen stellen das heißt jedes
halbe jahr kommt etwas neues und mit
diesen neuen produkten die wir gesehen
haben wie wir gehört haben
mit diesen neuen produkten werden wir
die märkte gehen und da freut sich die
industrie und handel drauf sind sie denn
mit den neuigkeiten auch zufrieden also
ist ja sonst ein bisschen mehr wenn wir
ehrlich sind aber es war ja doch schon
bemerkenswert es ist wahr wir sind sehr
zufrieden weil viel neues gesehen in
allen handy zb handybereich dem
tv-bereich wir haben spannende
übertragung live gesehen mit hologramm
zum beispiel von lg aus korea direkt in
die hinein
aber vor allem haben wir auch gesehen
dass viele unternehmen im direkten
umfeld die nicht auf der ifa jetzt
ausstellen
große unternehmen ihre eltern für ihre
pressekonferenzen ihre
produktvorstellung gemacht
das zeigt welche strahlkraft die ifa zu
diesem zeitpunkt hat für aussteller und
für die die außerhalb der ifas dieser
gemacht haben dann aber auch so für sie
als veranstalter der messe so ein
lachendes und ein weinendes auge
richtig wir glauben es wäre noch besser
gewesen derweil ihre präsentationen
gehalten hätten nicht nur finanziell für
uns sondern es wäre auch für die
aussteller die es für die
industriepartner die es außerhalb tiefer
gemacht haben wesentlich runder gewesen
weil kostengünstiger aber am ende
wir freuen uns dass rings um die fall so
viele innovationen vorgestellt werden
und das trägt uns natürlich jetzt ins
nächste jahr
wie haben sie denn auch ein persönliches
highlight wir haben uns ja hier auch
umgeschaut es gibt ja auch verrückte
gadgets irgendwie katzen rat führt zu
dicke katzen was war ihr highlight
ich darf das aber nicht sagen ich muss
ja mal sehr neutral bleiben weil wenn
ich den einen lobe werde ich bei dem
anderen und das bleibt ja alles geheim
ich weiß jetzt nur bild ich habe was
anderes als als für mich als das
absolute absoluten baum moment empfunden
in das war wirklich weiß ich schon
gesagt habe lg als der ceo also der der
technologische weltweite chef von lg aus
korea hier in ein 3d hologramm live
seine präsentation machte das zeigt dass
technikern was konnektivität was was die
die kommunikationstechnologie kann und
was bildtechnologie mittlerweile kann
man wohl die zukunft vielleicht steht
zum schluss ein kleiner ausblick auf
2011 gucken ja auf jeden fall
wie geht s weiter nächstes jahr kriegen
wir noch mal eine special edition also
ich hoffe nicht
für mehrere gründe zum einen die
hoffnung begründet sich darauf dass wir
nächstes jahr nicht wenn der korona
situation im sommer sein werden alle
experten alle mit denen wir sprechen
gehen davon aus und das schöne ist auch
die industrie auch die händler gehen
davon aus und wir haben mit vielen in
der industrie bereits gesprochen mit
vielen unserer aussteller was wir machen
ist dass wir das was dieses jahr geplant
wurde die großen stände die werden
kopiert und ins nächste jahr gebracht
und wir haben schon eine riesige anzahl
an flächen an aussteller verkaufen
können im sinne von die sind gebucht die
zahl darf ich jetzt noch nicht ganz
genau sagen wir liegen damit aber über
vorjahr
also wir haben eine stärkere buchung für
nächstes jahr als normalerweise
was zeigt alle wollen die ifa und keiner
der aussteller der gebucht hat hat
gesagt ich mache eine kleinere fläche
sondern sie wollen so wie wir die ifa
kennen nächstes jahr erscheinen und das
macht uns mut